[Music]
alabama we have a question from twitter
danish has a question for us
what is the difference between
minimalism and essentialism
i hate to get bogged down in definition
so ryan and i talk about what minimalism
is
minimalism is the thing that gets us
past the thing so we can make room for
life's most important things which
actually aren't things
at all now
you could call that a definition but
let's get to the essence behind each of
these in fact essence essential
essentialism nice now you can use these
words interchangeably and and so i don't
know what you mean by essentialism
versus minimalism but when i think of
essentialism i think it's often applied
in business context that's one way to
think about it or when we talk about
what is essential in our lives so in the
minimalist rule book which you can
download for free danish the
minimalists.com
rule book there are 16 rules for living
with less in there and one of those
rules well actually several of the rules
in the book i think will be helpful for
you but we talk about the no junk rule
in particular and in that rule we talk
about what is essential everything you
own can fit in one of three piles
it is either essential
so the essentialist would have only that
which is essential in our lives
right and one way to one way to think
about that is an ascetic might be an
essentialist right
now a minimalist however has something
that's in the second category we own
things
that add value to our lives they're
non-essential items meaning i could live
without my coffee table yeah but it adds
value to my life why would i deprive
myself of that now there could be a good
reason to deprive myself of it at least
temporarily to ask does it actually add
value to my life
and
temporary deprivation leads me to a
place of oh you know what the thing that
i thought added value the thing that i
thought might be essential
isn't essential
at all i remember ryan used to work with
clients
and he would help them through their
budgets and he would have them list
these what is essential what's
non-essential but value-adding and then
this third category is what is
junk
and
unfortunately we mistake we conflate the
non-essential value-adding things and
the junk it's the reason the average
american household has 300 000 items in
it because we think everything is
essential well of course if everything
is essential then nothing is essential
in fact i would argue that most of us
have very similar
essentials we all need food shelter
clothing education vocation
transportation but even those things
manifest differently transportation for
professor sean over here is taking the
bus to the studio or it could be walking
somewhere or it could be ryan's toyota
corolla or whatever it is right it
transportation looks different clothing
looks different if i gave ryan all my
clothes and he had i had all his clothes
all of a sudden we wouldn't have what
was appropriate for us
and so keeping that in mind what is
essential to me may not add any value to
your life whatsoever or it could just be
a non-essential one so it's a highly
perspectival
question what is essential for you and
then more important what adds value to
my life and if it doesn't actually add
value to my life
then it's junk and if it's junk well
then
i let it go
yeah so essentially what you're saying
is
minimalism
uh maybe starts with the central but it
doesn't end with the essential and like
that is that's actually really important
i think for people to understand with
minimalism
is that this is this is beyond just the
essential stuff
you know i it's i think one of the
things i get out of what you're saying
is that distinction between biologically
essential biologically essential and
psychologically optimal right
just because something isn't
biologically essential doesn't mean it's
not psychologically optimal
music might not be biologically
essential but it makes me a better
person art might not be biologically
essential so many of the things that
amplify the quality of our lives are
things that we could technically live
without but it isn't about
living according to technicalities right
it's about living meaningfully and as
fully as possible another thing i'll say
about the definition piece
is
it's it's sort of like the word optimism
for me if someone says are you an
optimist
my answer to that it depends on how you
understand the term according to the way
i define the word if you give me the
time to tell you what my definition of
optimism is i'm absolutely an optimist
but
i've seen some people
treat that word in a way that makes me
say oh yeah if that's what you mean by
optimism i'm definitely not an optimist
either right it's similar to the word
christian and a host of other things are
you a christian
tell me what you mean by that word first
before i commit to that because yeah i
am but you got to give me a minute to
tell you what i mean by that but if
you're just going to associate me with
everyone you've ever met who wears that
label no i'm a little more careful than
that
the important thing is to live in
accordance with your priorities and your
principles
and then allow whatever definitions you
use to be secondary to that are you an
essentialist are you a minimalist most
important thing is are you living the
way you want to live yeah the question
yeah the question is you know not only
do you survive but how do you thrive
and that's that's really um again what
minimalism i think josh and i really uh
yeah try and kind of help people
understand is like yeah you could
survive
without music you could survive without
other people in your life you can
survive in a cabin in the middle of
nowhere by yourself but you certainly
aren't going to thrive in fact um
to thrive to to be at peak health you
almost have to have some things in your
life i mean there are i don't know why
but i've seen like a couple studies over
the last month about cabin fever
and how legitimately like it's bad for
mental health to just be by yourself for
a certain amount of time and there are
certain people who can transcend that
but we have evolved so evolutionarily
there is a requirement to have people in
your life but even for each person it's
going to be different all three people
at this table and mallory who's
disembodied but somewhere in the room
this is a theory he's a voice float
around the room the immaterial essence
that hovers above i'm an extreme
introvert and so i don't spend a lot of
time with other people but i do need
those interactions with other people in
fact i thrive with ambient people i will
often work at a coffee shop
and
i don't interact with the people but
there's always the potential for
interaction and there is even casual
interaction from time to time or someone
will walk up and they'll notice me and
and where we moved recently
oh this is the private podcast like i
say i was up in ojai yesterday i was
just working at a coffee shop and this
guy walks in and it's the opposite of
what tk was saying a moment ago because
he's like oh do you live up here we just
came up here from la uh to hang out for
the weekend and i'm like yeah we love he
goes oh that makes a lot of sense
and he's like it's very
simple here
and so it's all about our interpretation
of a thing some people are like how
could you move to california you can't
be a minimalist and go to california
other people are like
you have to move to california to be a
minimalist and it's like well no neither
of those things are true the question is
what is appropriate for
you
oh man i tell you some of the horror
stories i have
around places i've lived and products
i've purchased
have proven to me
that the willingness to pay a little
more can go a long way in simplifying
your life there's no use in buying the
cheap product or living in the cheap
place just for the sake of being cheap
if it creates a part-time job of having
to look after it follow up on it get
help fix it when it breaks down and
maintain it over and over again there is
something to be said about paying the
price for peace of mind did you enjoy
this standalone patreon highlight if so
you can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free
you